[Musique]
j'aime bien google hic ça se marie bien
avec line le chef dominique truchon
adore cuisiner lannion de charlevoix
dans son restaurant de la malbaie enfin
petit puissant ou faux puis je la sers
avec un gastrique aller à ma sauce
un petit peu acide unis et le goût des
rames et un pesto à la vente
pour lui comme pour bien d'autres
l'appellation réservé est une valeur
ajoutée un produit typique
ouais je me suis toujours dit que les
produits de la région
ça fait partie de notre adn c'est comme
les couleurs pour un peintre
les gens viennent dans charlevoix pour
goûter charlevoix
quand un consommateur goûte à un produit
comme l'agneau qui a une certification
que l'appellation et gp agneau de
charlevoix vingt six est fondé sur
quelque chose de solide quelque chose
qui a été certifié quelque chose qui a
été accrédité des éleveurs d'agneaux de
la région ont créé une appellation
réservée pour garantir aux consommateurs
la qualité et l'authenticité de leurs
produits
on connaît bien l'igpn yacht charlevoix
d'ailleurs c'est une appellation
fondatrice mme le car des vies
réglemente les appellations et certifie
les produits gp comme l'agneau de
charlevoix
mais aussi les jpms de nouville le vin
le cidre de glace et le vin de glace du
québec une indication géographique
protégée
comme son nom l'indiqué c'est un produit
qui est en lien avec une particularité
une spécificité du territoire
ça peut être au niveau des qualités de
la production de l'histoire du folklore
de l'environnement pour créer l'igpn ion
de charlevoix
annie bérubé et d'un an troubles et ont
mis beaucoup de passion et d'efforts
ça c'est depuis 2009 mais c'est depuis
le début des années 2000 qui s'était
commencer la mesa prix qu'ils me disent
alors pour être capable en arriver
l'ordre dans le co2 logo is gp
effectivement quand on dit qu'il ya un
lien avec le territoire où donc le
terroir les particularités du territoire
c'est un fait mais dans le cas du niger
paix et dans le cas de toutes les
appellations réservées
il ya toujours un cahier des charges à
la base une bible sur lequel les
producteurs et les transformateurs se
base pour produire le produit ou le
transformer le vrai cahier de charges
c'est vraiment soldes c'est épais comme
ça
le cahier de charges ça implique bien
des choses un agneau doit être né sur le
territoire
nourri par sa mère et d'un minimum de
80% de fourrage cultivés sur place une
fois débité il doit peser entre 15 et 20
kg et respecter des critères rigoureux
de maigreur autres grains très faible
autour du cou leurs gosses parle une
finesse très bons amis et goûter
plusieurs à nouméa ma carrière puis
celui nosema clame
les gens ils trouvent que c'est trop
sévère pinzon on leur répond non parce
que ça nous permet justement d'avoir est
vraiment un produit uniforme
je trouve que l'igpn moi je trouve ça
laid un bon côté pour seul au prix oui
je dirais que c'est peut-être un peu
plus cher l'agneau de charlevoix
peut-être à cause de la rareté 6e gigot
d'agneau du québec coûte environ 35
dollars le kilo en épicerie la même
pièce certifié iger p coûte autour de 50
dollars le kilo
alors bon appétit on va voter jeunes
gens veulent-ils beaucoup plus rose
public
oui qui n'ont pas été très très doué
n'est pas grave du tout du tout sa fin
le fromage de vache de race canadienne
est une autre appellation chapeauté par
le quart tv une appellation de
spécificités la laiterie charlevoix
fabrique de fromage avec le lait de
cette vache unique
ici vous avez la région que vraiment
goûteux plein benatallah ça moi j'aime
bien cuisiner aussi et vous avez le
fromage c'est zéro rythme d'un excellent
fromage un peu plus par de fermes
toxines et ce fromage l'on pourrai pas
le faire avec un autre les que le lait
de cette machine n'a pas du tout le même
caractère
c'est certain c'est définitivement dans
l'art a ajouté bruno labbé et directeur
général de la laiterie charlevoix
il a fait le pari d'adhérer à cette
appellation de spécificités pour aider à
réintroduire la vache de race canadienne
c'est un enjeu particulier ce poids est
vide c'est une race qui parlait
pratiquement voix disparition est un
petit peu de missionnariat un petit peu
de nostalgie de ces troubles à des
années 19,5 et occuper l'ensemble du
territoire québécois
au milieu du siècle dernier la vache de
race canadienne faisait partie de notre
paysage agricole et même télévisuelle
les belles histoires des pays d'en haut
éduquer les vaches canadiennes qui ont
donné tout près de 12000 litres de lait
par année et plus près de 5,5
c'est un legs et plus riches plus riches
en protéines plus riche en acrobaties
dans les fromages intéressant ça reste
un peu marginale comme type de
production sont une race qui a pas été
développé le depuis près d'un siècle qui
apple qui a été un peu abandonné il est
évident que parallèlement une
appellation réservée
ça prend un programme d'amélioration
génétique on doit le faire pour le bien
de cette race là et si faisable
l'amélioration génétique de la vache de
race canadienne appuierait les efforts
déployés pour respecter le cahier de
charge de cette appellation spécifiques
les gens aiment ce produit là la
reconnaissance d'une appellation de
spécificités et pour largement établis
au québec
comment on va voir
en europe avec les appellations
d'origine et ce volet là du consommateur
de rechercher un produit d'appellation
et pas encore développé ici il faut
qu'on crée dans l'esprit des gens et un
réflexe de rechercher ces produits là
[Musique]